when Stefani reveals there was a time  she thought her music career baby over  that wasn't gonna do anymore  the MLB Network spoke with Gwen ahead of  her performance during all-star weekend  on Saturday I feel like I'm in a dream  that it was one of those things where I  had wanted to write for a long time and  nothing was really coming and just kind  of accepted that maybe and I had like I  had life you know I had children I had  just had like life going on and I'm so  grateful because I had such a long time  to kind of happy in the band and make  music and travel the world and I've been  so lucky so I kind of accepted I wasn't  going to do any more and then it just  life came at me and then I was like here  I go I'm ride this record make myself  feel better and it worked when has not  only been lucky and music recently but  also lucky in love with voice judge  Blake Shelton she performed her hit  single misery about her bow at the event  in San Diego Saturday  you